okay I've been thinking about whether or
not to do this story and it just has to
be done alright Joe Biden is really
weird about touching voters I'm not
talking about the creepy Uncle Joe stuff
related to women okay I'm talking about
something totally different here I'm
talking about how Joe Biden gets very
strange in even remotely contentious
conversations with men who ask him
questions on the campaign trail now I'm
gonna show you two videos of this normal
caveat if Biden's the nominee I'm voting
for Biden this is not about anything
other than this is strange I'd be a
hypocrite if I didn't point this out
since I point out strange behavior by
other candidates I talked about this in
a recent livestream and I pointed out
Joe's behavior is oddly aggressive
towards voters and some people
immediately said David Joe's not
aggressive you're just a beta male and
you're uncomfortable with confrontation
first of all this has nothing to do with
me and I encourage you to look at these
videos if you're listening to the
podcast or on the radio find the visual
component we're going to play and tell
me this is normal behavior if you
normally behave this way with people
around you in your real real life I want
to follow you around and see who you're
hanging out with because how Joe Biden
behaves in these clips with voters is
not normal let's look at the first one
from Iowa here Biden was asked about
committing to phase out fossil fuels and
look at how Joe Biden starts poking this
guy in the chest and getting aggressive
with him
[Music]
[Music]
this is not normal and as we look at the
clip again this time without audio you
see that the guy he's talking to has
this sort of uncomfortable smile on his
face because he recognizes Joe Biden's
behavior is abnormal Joe Biden's staffer
or handler there that's a voice we've
gotten to know well on the campaign
trail as she's often trying to get
people to move on and get Joe Biden away
from people she starts saying move on
you know get it get it get a move on
when Joe Biden starts getting irritated
with the voter here's another example of
this this one was when Biden was asked
about some of his views on fossil fuels
this was at a Biden event and a guy
showed up the guy had critical questions
tough questions but they are reasonable
questions and again Biden gets in the
guy's face gets really close to the guy
starts poking the guy in the chest
eventually tells the guy find someone
else to vote for go vote for someone
else and you again hear that same
handlers say thank you so much trying to
end it but Biden just insists on talking
and pokes the guy and then kind of holds
on to the guys open coat strange
behavior take a look why is it well then
you want to replace these gas lines
that's not gonna work we can't we got to
stop building and replacing pipeline
this is not about would I vote for Biden
over Trump of course I would vote for
Biden over Trump this is not about
anything other than something about the
gleam in Joe Biden's eye when he starts
poking voters and treating them like
this is extremely odd and again to
people who saw me talk about this
briefly on stream and said David you're
a beta this is not aggressive behavior
this is how men interact when they have
conversations are you telling me this is
how you are interacting with people in
your everyday life people you know
friends family coworkers I don't have
anyone around me who number one treats
people this way or number two would
allow themselves to be treated this way
so if you watch these videos and this
strikes you as the normal interactions
of adults who are talking I want to hear
from you because maybe it's me in you
know my [ __ ] liberal northeastern city
as many of our viewers like to say but
this is not normal behavior that I've
observed between adults anywhere this is
the type of behavior I see between drunk
adults on the Las Vegas Strip shortly
before they get into a fistfight right
that's what it reminds me of let me know
what you think we'll have a couple of
these clips on our Instagram page at
david pakman show while you're there
follow me on instagram at david pakman
as well if you enjoy shows like shark
tank or you're fascinated by
entrepreneurs and how they become
successful I've got something really
cool for you to check out the YouTube
channel we're partnering with called up
flip and you can find it at David
pakman.com slash up flip it's a new
channel they're hitting the ground
running with really excellent content
they're uploading new videos all the
time
in each video you meet a different
entrepreneur and take an in-depth look
at how they built their business from
the ground up you can examine the
business up-close learn their strategies
for success see what it's like to live a
day in their shoes as an entrepreneur
myself I find this stuff endlessly
interesting I love learning about how
business owners got to where they are
what motivates them what the turning
points were and everyone who's featured
in uplift videos have their own really
cool insights to share but it's content
that's really easy to appreciate even if
you don't have your own business
every entrepreneur on up flip has their
own story to tell they're all
fascinating check it out if you watch my
show check out up flip this is part of a
partnership we're doing with them
they're friends of ours I think you'll
really enjoy their content it's really
different it's unique there's something
for everybody check it out subscribe to
their channel at david pakman.com slash
up flip